it's not just vlm that's been exposed
but also the media's incessant lies
about the violence that that movement
sowed
especially in places like portland my
next guest andy noe recently returned
there
to document the city's continued
struggle against the antifa-led violence
well it took just one night for
suspected thugs of the antifa nature to
find andy
and send him to the hospital joining me
now andy noe editor-at-large of the
post-millennial
author of unmasked he's joining us from
an undisclosed location which we're not
going to reveal for his own safety
andy um how were they able to find you
and attack you so
quickly so
as your viewers probably know just about
two years ago i was beaten badly by them
when i was covering a public
demonstration in downtown portland
but that didn't silence me i continued
to do my reporting come up with
different ways
i wised up this particular time i was
actually undercover fully
in their uniform marching along with
them
i think what gave it away though is they
paid attention to the fact that i wasn't
engaging in
criminal activities with them such as
throwing projectiles
at law enforcement or trying to damage
the central police station
so they sent people over to interrogate
me
and then they pulled off my mask and my
goggles
and shouted that's him get him get him
and i ran for my life throughout
downtown portland in the middle of the
street
there was no police the fastest one and
the mob caught up to me
tackles me to the ground and was
repeatedly
punching me on the back of my head in my
face
and i was pleading for mercy he got
distracted
i got up and ran into the nearest thing
that was open because most of the
businesses in downtown portland are
boarded up which was a nines hotel
when i got in i i played with the hotel
securities and staff to call 9-1-1
and they told me that i needed to put on
a mask in that i had to leave oh god
yeah i want to show i want to show an
image of someone you say may have
assaulted you she also reportedly yelled
we're going to beat the
blank out of you b uh andy have you
given this photo to police i mean i
don't know you can't really see much in
that photo of course the man
another reason we don't want the masks
is you can't identify anyone
committing acts of criminality have you
heard from the police
i have not heard back from a detective
at all
which you know i have more than two
dozen reports
to police of death threats people
showing up at my family's home
that was reason why i had to flee
portland last year the reason why i came
back was
to care for my elderly parents on a
certain family matter
and you know it's important for
for journalists to be on the ground to
see um it's important to be on the
ground andy but
apparently you have a target on your
back and i think you know
you you can't just keep getting beaten
in the head it's just not going to be
good for you
absolutely uh you just can't i mean
someone else is going to have to pick up
the mantle here because they know who
you are and they're just going to beat
you and
they're probably going to try to kill
you um they cou and they would if they
could
uh andy uh thank you for your continued
reporting but you got to be careful out
there thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else